What's the main difference between the true rife and the Atelier Robin?
Again, I used to use the true rife for years and years only which were right, and we switched to the Atelier Robin.
We basically only sold the Atelier Robin.
For those that are on this call or listening to this, that will true right. We're like, what?
What's up there? I wanted to tell your Robin, too.
Well, Atelier Robin didn't come out until last year, so we couldn't have received one.
At Atelier Robin only started producing machines for us and a few other practitioners solely because of some of the changes that happened with the true rife.
So true rife actually used the board, the frequency board, that Atelier Robin made.
So if you have an older true rife, technically is kind of an Atelier Robin. I mean, the board is the Atelier Robin.
It doesn't call the characteristics and beneficial character qualities of the Atelier Robin P220
because Patrick Robin proved the board so much and tried to get Mike with Mike on true rife to use his approved technology.
And of course, Mike was a business man and regardless about making judgment calls on my Mike did what he did, but he stuck with what he used.
And then when true rife was sold back to the half years ago, the new owners, you know, made some different business decisions to not use the Atelier Robin board and use what made out of China.
And they made different decisions. I'm not saying good or bad or judging what they did, but it made me question the integrity of the company and the integrity of the machine.
We'll be forward and we started looking for alternatives and the Patrick Robin to he was creating this for us and other practitioners and it's just a far better machine with a lot better benefits.
So the benefit of Atelier Robin is if you put it on a oscilloscope, it holds frequency much better. Now, I would say that the older true rife probably holds them the same.
A friend of I tested it with an oscilloscope and it's the newer true rice that had the issues.
But that's that was an objective test. And then the benefits in Atelier Robin is that you could run the level of harmonic frequency. And I talked about that a lot, but I think that's hugely beneficial for killing pathogens and killing choices.
So I think it's a far superior machine at this point.
Though I think the older true rice are still great machines and still obviously we have patients that have been using them for a decade and more and still alive when they're supposed to be dead, you know, a decade or more ago.
So it works. It worked for me. That's what I used to overcome by cancer. It's just the newer new machines are different and I lost faith with them. But I've always said
from the beginning of my practice, you know, was always that patients come first. I'm not loyal to a machine. I'm not loyal to how much you could make to eat a certain therapy or how much you can make selling a machine or anything like that.
It's always what would I use myself? What would I sell, you know, my old family members? And if I wouldn't sell that to my old family members that I won't sell to patients, I wouldn't recommend it to my self or to a family member. I would not recommend it to a patient.
In just a way, the whole experience too convicted, he wouldn't let me do that. He would crash a bird before he would let me do something like that.